Republicans have started the dog and
pony show hearings and the first one
where they wanted to dress down and
Grill Twitter Executives about
anti-conservative bias has backfired so
spectacularly Republicans utterly
humiliating themselves that hopefully
they are talking behind closed doors and
saying we gotta stop doing this stuff to
ourselves because this did not go well
the whole point here was to bring
Twitter Executives in front of a house
panel and to grill them and expose how
they were blocking Trump and banning
conservatives and all of these different
things they did nothing of the sort and
in fact only confirmed how clueless and
ignorant they are about everything from
the way technology Works to what the
first amendment is and isn't but we will
get to that let's look at some clips
here is a Lauren Boberg
Furious principled defiant saying who
the hell do you think you are when you
silenced me or something take a listen
to this did you Shadow ban my account
yes or no did you Shadow ban my account
again not to the best of my recollection
so the answer is Mr Roth yes you did I
found out last night from Twitter staff
that you suppressed my account for this
tweet it's a freaking joke about Hillary
Clinton not being angry that she she
seems completely unhinged couldn't rig
her election it's
[Music]
a nine and I'm realizing part of the
problem with why these things go wrong
is their lack of ability to read out
loud with proper tone and detonation
Lauren bobert understand is reading this
rant that's supposed to make Twitter
look really bad but because her reading
skills translate you know you one of the
things that sometimes can be useful when
when you're doing this type of thing
is you develop a skill where anybody can
really do it you're reading one or two
phrases ahead of what you're saying so
that you can properly contextualize and
have the right tone for what you're
saying now so it doesn't end up sounding
weird when you get to the next thing she
just seems unable to do it so she sounds
very silly
the account filter so I
included me from top searches prevented
notifications for non-followers and much
more this is considered an aggressive
visibility filter you silenced members
of Congress from communicating with
their constituents you can you silenced
me from communicating with the American
people over a freaking joke now who the
hell do you think that you are who the
hell do you think you are
this was really the theme
acting as if criminal things took place
and pretending that it only applied to
right Wingers which we now know of
course that it did not then they brought
in clay Higgins who just seems very dim
and Confused like it genuinely doesn't
seem like he even understands Twitter
and he seemed to be threatening these
ex-twitter employees
with a rest for what crimes I have no
idea let's see if we can figure it out
you ladies and gentlemen interfered with
the United States of America 2020
presidential election knowingly and
willingly that's the bad news is going
to get worse right because this is the
investigation part later comes the
arrest part
the Europe for what for what crimes
who's getting arrested what are you even
talking about attorneys are familiar
with that
Mr chairman I'd like to spend five hours
with these ladies and gentlemen doing
depositions surely yet to come but for
right now I yield the balance of my time
to my yeah
um earlier during the event and and
again this is all
of course this is all stage managed for
an electorate meaning people who vote
for these Republicans who don't know any
damn better and I understand that but to
anybody with an ability to evaluate what
actually took place here this is a
complete and total joke here's the very
same clay Higgins submitting random
items he found on the internet for
inclusion in the Congressional Record
also submit for the record a timeline of
uh events with cited sources outline and
strong evidence of the Boden family
organized criminal actions
indicate that we've crossed the
threshold of reasonable suspicion we've
crossed the Rubicon based on this thing
I found on Gateway pundit I like this
timeline submitted for the record excuse
me Mr chairman all right just where is
that from that timeline
timeline in my hand boss up I'll get it
to you shortly what did he say what
where is it from I mean I've got to hear
that again from that timeline
timeline in my hand boss up boss up what
is he talking about I'll get it to you
shortly
um
okay so let's include random items from
the internet then it went to a
representative sessions who took this as
an opportunity to bless Elon Musk that
was you knew that was coming thank you
very much so I will say it God bless
Elon Musk yeah
because I I think I feel that way it was
Elon Musk that revealed
data that uncovered a disturbing cabal
right there was a cabal it was uncovered
a cabal in which both the Trump
Administration and the Biden campaign
had the email addresses of people at
Twitter and they could email them and
say hey we'd like this removed now we
are going to get to what Trump wanted
removed from Twitter and again this is
part of the total backfire of this but
let me not get ahead of myself we then
go to Congressman James Comer
Congressman James Comer has been a major
promulgator of conspiracy theories about
the balloon as we have spoken about here
he tries to convince a lawyer to waive
attorney-client privilege for no reason
other than he wants to as I think we've
notified the committee and we've had
these conversations with Twitter as well
to try to resolve this issue prior to
coming up here today I don't have
anything in writing that clears me in my
ethical responsibilities to my former
client right with respect to answering
questions that I think fall squarely
within the attorney client privilege so
unfortunately I don't think I can go
beyond what I've said there already sir
yeah and fortunately Mr Speaker you're
assertion that the attorney-clamp
privilege uh it it's overruled as to
this particular question and answer so
uh will you
please answer the question we're
overruling attorney client privilege
just right here just I'm just doing it
with my gavel Jordan
point of order Mr chairman
State you put uh well I as I understand
it because we just went through this in
the January 6 committee where multiple
Witnesses asserted attorney-client
privilege including people who weren't
covered by it at all and ultimately
that's that's the funny thing remember
the degree to which attorney-client
privilege was cited by Trump
Administration people when there were
like no lawyers even in the room and now
all of a sudden an actual lawyer in a
completely legitimate use of
attorney-client privilege no no no just
talk about it anyway tell us anything
work to decide so I don't think there's
I don't think there's anything we can do
within the committee at this point
unless I'm missing something no uh Jamie
Raskin is missing nothing uh whatsoever
this was humiliating a really
interesting moment uh congresswoman
Alexandria ocasio-cortez she took some
of the time she had to detail how this
account lives of tick-tock actually
incited harassment against Real World
Health Care workers at Boston Children's
Hospital but was still allowed to remain
on Twitter again sort of disproofed by
counter example A compelling moment take
a look at this Miss navaroli are you
familiar with the account Libs of tick
tock
I have heard of it from the news yes
um Mr Roth are you familiar with this
account
yes ma'am I am
are you aware from that from August 11th
to August 16th that account posted false
information about Boston Children's
Hospital claiming that they were
providing hysterectomies
for children
yes I am aware of that and other claims
from the account and are you aware that
this lie was then circulated by other
prominent far-right influencers
yes
and are you aware that all these claims
uh which I have reiterated were false
culminated in a real-life harassment and
ultimately a bomb threat
to the Boston Children's Hospital
yes I am aware and this account is still
on that platform today isn't it
regrettably yes it is despite inspiring
a bomb threat due to the right-wing
incitement of violence against trans
Americans in this country because they
cannot
let go of this obsession
with fixating violence and inciting
violence against trans and LGBT people
in addition to immigrants in addition to
women of color this is a party that
cannot pick on anyone their own size
yeah so this really just a terrible idea
for republicans and the idea that this
was a concerted effort to silence the
ride has been so widely debunked the
flopped Twitter files themselves
debunking that notion we have video here
of Congressman Pat Fallon citing a
completely dubious poll saying if the
hunter Biden stuff had been left on
Twitter Trump would have actually won so
there in the media Research Center
polled Democratic voters in 2020 swing
States and found that 17 would have
changed their vote if they had known the
contents and evidence of the New York
Post story
president Trump lost
key States Georgia Pennsylvania
Arizona and Wisconsin by collectively
just over 100 000 votes yeah and if this
is accurate this poll 3.2 million votes
could have swung
and he only needed a teeny fraction of
those 3.2 million yeah it's Twitter's
fault because they censored Hunter
Biden's genitalia that Trump did not
ultimately win now remember it is
against Twitter's terms of service and
it is a crime in almost all 50 states to
publish explicit images of an individual
without that individual's consent and
that is why that content was removed so
we eventually got to a summary from
democratic Congressman Maxwell Frost
which is really good I I I'm a fan of
this guy so far from what I have seen
and his summary is completely correct
sitting here for over two hours and I'm
still not really seeing the point of
this hearing me neither is it the solve
the problems of the American people what
people are struggling with no no we get
it my Republican colleagues wish that
the hunter Biden story would have helped
them win the 2020 election and that
didn't happen and so they're angry about
it and that's the point of this hearing
yeah you know it was actually the the
foundation of the Chairman's opening
statement it's why he brought up that
that poll on the 2020 election that's
what this is all about yes it is about
that and about continuing to turn
Americans against big Tech platforms not
for reasons that should make us
concerned about the platforms but for
Imaginary reasons uh like this decidedly
uh anti-conservative bias that they
claim exists this is what you can expect
for the next two years Republicans who
are essentially the school bully
while complaining they are the victims
of bullying that's fundamentally what
you have here and we are going to have
pointless hearing after senseless
investigation for the next two years
hopefully those hearings will blow up in
their faces as much as this one did
where they make a claim and they swear
it's true and then it's proven that
they're wrong but we're still going to
have a hearing because we still say it's
true and of course it's not it doesn't
matter
to many of their supporters that these
hearings blow up in their faces because
their supporters don't live in reality
and they don't care now there's a couple
things from this hearing that I did not
include in this summary because I think
they're worthy of their own discussion
and let's get to one of those things
right now
did you know that every year 30 million
trees are cut down to meet the demand of
toilet paper in the United States alone
here's something really simple you can
do to fight climate change a little bit
in your home our sponsor real paper
makes toilet paper 100 from bamboo
stocks which keep growing forever no
trees are cut down it's shipped right to
your door in plastic free packaging it's
fluffy it's soft like regular toilet
paper you're not making any quality
sacrifice and for every box you buy real
paper donates to reforestation efforts
Across America through their partnership
with one tree planted so instead of the
toilet paper you're currently buying
which cuts down trees and wastes plastic
use real paper actively helping the
planet you can set up a recurring
subscription so you're always stocked or
do a one-time purchase the average
American uses 50 pounds of toilet paper
or more every year make the easy switch
switch to real paper you'll get 30 off
your first order plus free shipping go
to realpaper.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman the link is down below